oscar-winner Kevin Spacey is apologizing
to fellow actor Anthony Rapp over a new
harassment claim Rapp said space he made
a sexual advance on him when he was 14
years old
Rapp appears on the CBS all access
series Star Trek Discovery he said by
sharing his story he is quote standing
on the shoulders of the many courageous
women and men who have been speaking out
to shine a light and hopefully make a
difference Michelle Miller is here with
a reaction from Spacey and Hollywood
Michelle good morning good morning
Spacey tweeted he does not remember the
alleged encounter which wrapped detailed
in an interview with BuzzFeed still
Spacey says he's beyond horrified by the
story and he says it has encouraged him
to do something he's never done before
publicly acknowledged that he is gay
snake in 1a in 1986 Kevin Spacey was a
26 year old starring on Broadway he met
fellow Broadway actor Anthony Rapp that
year Rapp was 14 you're out here
temperature rap now stars in Star Trek
discovery and was in the original cast
of the Broadway musical rent in 1986
Rapp says he recalls being alone in
Spacey's apartment after a party my
impression was that he was drunk he
picked me up and then he lays down on
top of me I was aware that he was trying
to get with me sexually he says he was
able to squirm away and left Spacey star
of the Netflix series house of cards is
a two-time Oscar winner Carrie hosted
the Tony Awards in June he joked about
the long-standing rumors about his
sexuality Spacey tweeted that he doesn't
remember the encounter quote if I did
behave then as he describes I owe him
the sincerest apology the story has
encouraged me to address other things
about my life I've had relationships
with both men and women I choose now to
live as a gay man people on social media
are noting that coming out as gay
completely separate from addressing
allegations of being a sexual predator
you could argue that coming out as gay
in this particular moment might deflect
attention away from the allegations
against him and we reached out to rap
for a response to stasi statement our
spacy statement but have not heard back
but other celebrities are reacting
including Harvey Weinstein accused of
Rose McGowan who tweeted keep focus on
Anthony rap be the victims voice Gael
very important conversation have thank
you very much Michelle